el presidente Turco recepta y perdonan
ha firmado oficialmente el decreto para
la convocatoria electoral de las
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias en Turquía para el
próximo 14 de mayo dentro de 2 meses
estas elecciones se prevén claves para
el futuro de Turquía porque la
popularidad erdogan está muy baja desde
hace tiempo sobre todo desde la crisis
económica que a través de Turquía una
crisis inflacionaria de evaluación de la
moneda enorme Además del terremoto que
ocurrió Hace un mes que ha debilitado el
gobierno César exactamente cuánto Porque
los sondeos empiezan a salir ahora y
explican que erdogan sí que ha salido
debilitado Aunque es probablemente más
una galvanización de la oposición turca
que ya ha decretado su candidato lo hizo
este mismo lunes que mal clichero
principal partido del opositor será el
que se enfrente a un erdogan que según
la mayoría de los sondeos perdería esas
elecciones sin embargo muchas cosas
pueden pasar aún en estos dos meses la
gran duda que persiste ahora mismo es
cómo se van a celebrar estas elecciones
sobre todo las 10 provincias afectadas
por el terremoto que han sido
completamente cuya población se ha ido
de estas provincias aún el consejo
electoral supremo aún no ha explicado
Cómo se realizarán estas elecciones ahí
si las personas que antes vivían ahí que
viven en otras provincias podrán
participar de alguna manera de alguna
manera estas elecciones o las nuevas
provincias o tendrán que viajar a las
anteriores lo que sí que muchos dudan de
una de una seguridad electoral que se
breve muy difícil no solo por el
terremoto sino porque erdogan puede
perder el poder en Turquía después de 20
años al mando del país y esto crearía un
cambio enorme sobre todo en Casos Eso sí
de que ganase una la elección una
oposición cada vez más fuerte más
organizada en Turquía